what's up guys i'm dave klein aka dave
control the world of eldon ring is
absolutely massive so there's a good
chance there's something you might have
missed even if it's small so here are 10
things you didn't know you could do in
elden ring for this episode i'm going to
focus on lim grave as to avoid late game
spoilers
marget's shackle if you're struggling
against the first major boss fight of
eldon ring market the fel omen fear not
for the game actually includes a handy
way to make this boss fight easier the
way to do this is by purchasing market's
shackle
what is it well shackles were used to
bind the cursed people called the omen
and these ones were made to keep a
particular omen under strictest
confinement though faint the shackles
still retain vestiges of power enough to
trap the once bound market on earth if
only for a short time once you get this
shackle use it against market and even
other omen creatures you may find and it
will shackle them momentarily allowing
you to wail in some hits and you can use
it multiple times so don't worry about
running out of uses
so where do you find this ever so useful
item well head to the merkwater cave you
can find this in between the merkwater
catacombs and agile lake right at this
section of the map you'll know you're
close by when you get invaded by bloody
finger narrages don't worry bloody
finger hunter yura will be there to help
you through it enter the merkwater caves
open up the chest and who should you
find but none other than patches
yes the very same patches that is in
just about every recent from software
game
once you get him to have health he'll
give up on the fight and act as a
merchant rest at a site of grace and
return to him and you'll now be able to
purchase the market shackles from him
for 5 000 runes a steep price but maybe
not so steep when you consider just how
useful this item can be
bock the seamster it can be very easy to
miss some npcs in elton ring in fact
some of them are even hidden as
inanimate objects one of these npcs is
bach the seamster who you can find it in
a small forested area near the agile
lake north side of grace or here on a
map
bach has been transformed into a tree
and you'll be clued in on his location
by him calling out when you run by near
him
you you there
could you help us out cully
and the only way to help him out coley
is by hurting him
no seriously you'll either need to swing
at his tree with a weapon or roll into
him to restore him to normal
once you do this bach will thank you by
gifting you a number of mushrooms and
suggest his next location my knees start
knocking
just thinking about that god-awful cave
on the shore after this you can find
bach in the coastal cave to the west
side of limgrave he'll clue you in on
the ganky nature of the dungeons bosses
but defeat them and you'll find his
prized sewing needle you can give back
to him and progress his quest line where
bach will be able to alter certain items
of your wardrobe for you while this is
essentially the same thing as the
tailoring tools you'll also get for
defeating the demi human chief's boss
fight and that you can use without bach
at any site of grace bach will alter
your wardrobe for you for free whereas
doing it at a site of grace will cost
runes being a dick pays off getting high
level equipment early on can be a little
tough in eldon ring you may not meet the
stat requirements and the more and more
you upgrade your weapons the more and
more expensive it is with smithing
stones that are harder to come by
earlier on however there's a very very
quick and easy way to get a very good
starting weapon
if you're willing to be a dick head to
castlemore into the south which is being
besieged by menials at the top of the
castle you can find the warden of
castlemorn edgar whose daughter irina
you can find earlier on the way to
castle mourn edgar is doing his best to
hold the line and keep the castle from
being fully captured by the menials
while protecting their special weapon
i'm afraid castlemorn
won't hold much longer
take this by way of apology but you know
edgar i feel like a failure to hold the
line like this
deserves to be severely punished
for killing edgar he'll drop a plus 8
halberd which is pretty damn good at
this point in the game when you should
be tackling castle mourn so hey maybe
being a dick does pay off nighttime
struggles
exploring the lands between at night can
bring a host of new challenges for
example if you explore the bridge just
south of the aguila lake north side of
grace at night the night's cavalry boss
fight will appear
similarly the same thing can be said at
the castlemore and rampart site of grace
on the weeping peninsula but these
aren't the only unique things that will
happen at night for example head back to
the church of ella at night you know the
same church where you find kali the
merchant if you do so after getting
torrent you'll find the witch who calls
herself rena rena will then gift you the
spirit calling bell which will allow you
to summon spirit ashes as well as some
lone wolf spirit ashes
but that's not all head up to storm hill
and you can find the war master shack
east of the stormhill shack roderica
likes to hang out in normally you'll
find bernal at the warmaster shack who's
kind enough to teach you some weapon
arts however head here at night and
bernal will be missing if he's not rest
at your sight of grace again making sure
it's night and you'll find he's no
longer there walk inside and you'll be
ambushed by none other than a
bell-bearing hunter he has a telekinetic
sword so have fun with that one
rodericka speaking of roderica you can
find her in the storm hill shack
saddened because all of her buddies left
to get grafted by godric that grafted
the stormhill shack is easy enough to
find as is right on the path to
stormville castle speaking to rodericka
here she'll gift you spirit jellyfish
ashes which are honestly pretty awesome
she also happens to be a very important
npc and you continue her questline in
one of two ways
the way that's probably technically the
correct way would be by searching
stormville castle before you defeat
godric which will progress her quest
line you can find a grafted scion within
the castle below the rampart tower side
of grace you don't have to defeat him
here but what you do need to do is head
to the side room near this where you'll
find a number of corpses piled up and a
couple of dogs on the pile of corpses
you'll find the chrysolids momento bring
this back to roderica and she'll head
off to the round table hold here at the
round table hold roderica will thank you
for helping her out and gives you a
golden seed you're now free to continue
her questline however let's say you
missed that and she leaves before you
can finish her quest fear not as
returning to stormhill shack you can
find some flowers she's left as well as
a golden seed and she'll still end up in
the round table hold like i said she's
an important npc
blive aka guts
blive is the best he's a giant wolf
warrior who's pretty much just guts from
berserk but as a wolf and i love him
he's also the wolf you may have seen an
artwork during loading screens of the
game as well as one of the first
trailers to the game but finding him can
actually be a little tricky so here's
what you need to do head east of
limgrave into mistwood it's the large
forest just east of limgrave you can't
miss it in fact if you're doing patch's
questline he will transport you right
into mistwood with his chest trap if you
walk around the miswood ruins early in
the game you'll hear a howling noise
not much you can do here yet but return
back to the church of ella and speak
with kali the merchant now that you've
heard the howling you'll have a new line
of dialogue you can get from kalei about
it kali will teach you the snap gesture
now return to miss wood and then miss
wood ruins use the snap gesture and
you'll beckon blythe to come down and
speak to you from here you can continue
on early parts of his questline all of
that said if you missed this don't worry
you can still do later parts of life's
questline later in the game it's all
good you'll just miss the beginning of
this quest line
you can escape transporter traps
something i brought up in the last point
was the transporter trap that patches
sets for you if you open that chest up
there's nothing you can do about it
you're getting transported to miss wood
however that said there are many more
transporter trap chests hidden
throughout the lands between and as it
turns out you can actually dodge away
from these and are given a decent amount
of time to react and get away before
they ensnare you to do so it's actually
pretty simple when you open the trap
just roll backwards right after you open
it and after realizing it's a
transporter trap and boom transportation
avoided but let's say you're curious
about where it goes you can still open
the transporter trap again at any point
and it will still transport you to the
same location as before
stone sword keys this one is just a bit
of paying attention to details but it's
kind of fun the stone store keys you get
in the game can be used on imp statue
locks that lock away hidden areas that
typically contain good loot or some
horrendous boss you're going to have to
fight
however sometimes these imps take one
stone star key and other times they take
two the way to tell how many they'll
take is simply by looking at the imp
statue all of them have two heads but in
many of them there's already a stone
sword key in the bottom head which you
can visually see if there's a stone
store key already in one of them which
is honestly most of these you'll only
need one stone sword key to unlock the
area however for the ones where there
aren't any stone sword keys in the m
statue that's when you know you'll need
two of your stone sword keys
stormville castle skip alright so you
made it to stormville and you're
struggling but you want to explore lyria
which is north of stormville castle and
just have fun exploring more well have
no fear for you can actually entirely
bypass stormville castle
from the stormhill shack site of grace
instead of heading into stormville
castle head straight north along the
path that goes underneath the giant
bridge and to the destroyed bridge close
to the water here you'll find a finger
reader npc near the bridge don't worry
about her though just keep heading north
along the destroyed bridge and you'll
discover that even though it's destroyed
you can actually drop down along its
remains and then hug the east side of
stormville castle
continue north along this path and
you'll eventually pop out right at leone
of the lakes and the lake-facing cliffs
site of grace
hidden stormville castle tree spirit
stormville castle has a massive hidden
underneath dudgeon area that you'll have
to take a leap of faith to find this
dungeon includes many goodies and a
minor boss remember the tree spirit boss
i showed earlier that absolutely wrecked
me well you can find one here however
most of the time defeating these tree
spirits makes them drop a golden seed so
it's definitely worth fighting them as
they'll add to your golden seed count
not only will you find this tree spirit
and golden seed for heading down here
but you'll also find a stone sword key
and the prince of death's postul which
is a talisman you can equip that will
raise your vitality
to find this area start at the left side
chamber site of grace within stormville
castle leave the open door that isn't
locked and go around the side next to
the right where you'll find a dead enemy
looking down
look down as well and you'll see a path
you can fall on fall down here and then
continue to work your way down
and there you go have fun fighting a
tree spirit
i hope you learned something new and if
not i'll have another video for you guys
next week with even more fun fact toys
and hidden things so i hope you'll look
forward to that and enjoy
and i'll see you guys next time peace
[Music]